[Music]
crime homelessness violence and filth
are now the norm in Liberal cities and
the voters don't seem divined take the
chaos in Seattle the blue city has
surpassed last year's homicide total
with three months left in the year and
violent crime is up 25 percent Jesse
sent Johnny to the progressive hellscape
where residents mocked the idea that the
city is spiraling out of control
I've never seen any crime in Seattle
I've never seen any of it I've seen fun
and laughter and laughter and fun I
don't believe that number people they're
you know get robbed out here carjacked
I've never heard of anyone getting
robbed Prime is a social issue that
could be solved by giving people their
basic needs it's not a thing that
happens just on the street people don't
just come up and try to rob people on
the street do you walk around every day
like someone's gonna rob me every second
Seattle decriminalized drug use and then
they criminalize it again oh my God who
are you getting these facts from you're
from New York apparently you're
listening to the wrong people I saw a
lot of people shooting up on my way down
here oh did you okay
and they were bothering you I was in a
car but you know people oh no you're in
the car oh no
oh no well the situation sounds like a
big joke to voters but Target is taking
notice they are now closing stores in
Seattle and other liberal cities over
concerns of thefts and worker safety and
now the liberal media is throwing in the
towel on the Progressive Movement the
New York Times is admitting black lives
matter Occupy Wall Street and hashtag me
too are total failures it didn't change
anything and are just symbolic quote for
instance polling shows that most black
Americans support major changes to
policing but not less policing much of
black lives matter however focused on
cutting police funding
Jesse I have to go to you the arrogance
uh and the ignorance of Seattle
residents that Johnny interviewed is is
shocking I mean how could they be
Clueless
well they're in denial and if you look
at the demographics of the city it's
understandable it is a very highly
educated city very white very lgbtq very
secular and they all believe in the same
thing which is criminalizing crime is
racist there is someone a victims
advocate who just quit after 25 years
because she said Crime Victims are being
pressured by courts to recommend
non-prison sentences so if you get
assaulted you're supposed to want that
person to go to rehab instead of prison
and they're being bullied into doing
this
it's about white guilt and it's about
people learning from these professors
that in order to make everybody equal
they can't punish criminality and it's
gotten so bad that criminals are now
coming into the city we did it with sex
offenders we used to see these sex
offenders go to places like Vermont or
California where they know they can get
away with preying on children because
they know that their soft sentences
they're doing the same thing here and
it's predatory and it's such a shame
because that city is the fourth largest
port in North America huge trade with
Asia they got biotech they've got Boeing
they got Microsoft it's just it's so
much potential but you see what they've
done politically they never vote
Republican and so they've continued to
vote Democrat year after year referendum
after referendum and the quality of life
keeps going down and they've accepted
the death spiral and I don't like to
speak in generalities you know I don't
do that but when you go there there
there is a kind of a dark Paul that
hangs over the city it's it's it's sad
it's you're not getting sunlight there
people are depressed I haven't I've saw
an abundance of purple hair an abundance
of masks more masks there than I see
here uh per capita and it is remembered
Nirvana remember the grunge scene
it's the same type of people too much
Patagonia judge it was a very unhealthy
looking crowd and I can't help but
notice it's all tied together Simon
Cowell noticed it too remember American
Idol he said this to USA Today in 2006
they had the worst bunch of miserable
singers that I've ever met in my life it
was two days of total misery
you know Jessica Oakland today uh
Oakland businesses went on strike today
because of the crime and house Judiciary
actually convened in Chicago to discuss
it with the community we just found out
before we went on air the target is
closing nine stores across four states
all in Democrat cities and yet the
Democrats seem to be doubling down on
this social justice you know no cash
bail Illinois just went no cash pal at
all how do you justify this
well I don't have to justify it which is
the beauty of not being in an
Administration
of policies that these DA's have been
carrying out are not working and there
is a dichotomy between what the DA's
thinking what the police Chiefs think
who are often black and Democrats as
well or that Mayors think and you do see
across some democratic cities that there
has been pushback on it you you were
even saying a few weeks ago about London
breed that she's changed the way that
she's talking in San Francisco you saw
Chessa Boudin got thrown out there
um you see in Philadelphia a little bit
of tougher talk but if you have Larry
krasner as the D.A it's necessarily
going to change how people are punished
what I wanted to say about the people
that Johnny was interviewing though is
that this is a deeply personal thing
when your city that you love changes and
like as a native New Yorker I hate to
have to talk about a downward spiral
that the Subway has changed so much that
I grew up going on the subway every
single day with my mom and I would not
bring my daughter on there these are
places that we love they're important
American cities talked about that with
San Francisco right this is one of our
biggest tourist attractions it's
gorgeous and it was the best of us and
now it has changed and I think that you
get that kind of response especially
when someone puts a camera in your face
that you're not going to want to just
say my city is a disaster I would point
out though that the FBI statistics for
the first half of the year
show that in 30 cities Across America
and not in Seattle I understand that's
an outlier here
that homicides have dropped by 9.4
percent compared to the same period last
year it is not below pre-pandemic levels
but it is improving in that sense that
doesn't mean that the crime and the
petty theft and violent crime in some
places isn't a problem but there is a
larger story here than just everything
as a hellscape you know Martha Jessica
talks about prosecutors these cases
don't even get to prosecutors because
the defendants if they are arrested are
let out and don't even come back but
what about the tacona Tacoma Pierce
County Health Department outside of
Seattle running a campaign telling kids
how to safely use fentanyl as opposed to
telling them not to do drugs whatever
happened to their programs and all these
other programs no I mean it's a great
point I mean we should be discouraging
because it's very hard to discourage
drug use these days because marijuana is
legal in so many states all across the
country I was reading a piece this week
about the New York City teachers are
upset because so many kids are coming to
class high in the morning so they're
already way behind in their schoolwork
they've already you know suffered from
these horrific lockdowns that set them
all back and now you know now they show
up for school high in large enough
numbers that teachers are speaking out
about it and they're concerned about it
so we don't need to tell kids how to
safely take fentanyl what we need to
tell them is that they shouldn't take
any drug that wasn't handed to them by
their parent or their doctor because
they don't know what it might be laced
with and and we've seen so many people
lose their lives that way I find it
really interesting Jessica your point
about not wanting to admit that the city
that you love is in trouble and I think
there's an interesting divide on that
because you do hear from people in New
York City who are very upset about
what's happening and they're very open
about it and they want to complain about
it because they want it to get better
but what we see in that video are people
who don't want to see what's happening
right before their eyes and and I just
find that curious because says the truth
hurts but we can't change it unless we
accept what's going on and I see
increasing acceptance across the country
I think of that woman whose head was
bloodied who pushed to defund the police
in Minneapolis and she said you have to
arrest these teenagers who did this to
me in my driveway they have to go to
jail so I I sense a change but I think
we have to be clear-eyed about what's
going on and those people clearly do not
appear to be Greg what do you make of
the fact that the the New York Times
seems to be coming around the
progressive policies in a lot of these
cities have been a failure well
I love how they they when you when
you've been acting stupid for a long
time you still have to pretend to be
smart so they attribute all of this to
something called Elite capture rather
than just pure idiocy what this was was
a liberal Crusade for symbolic symbolic
pointless actions usually propagated by
guilty white liberals and It ultimately
ended in a loss of life all around
because what it did is it diverted
attention from real practical solutions
to something like and these are their
examples this is great this is what they
wrote did times mention this uh the
winners of prestigious cultural Awards
have become more diverse media
organizations now capitalize the word
black
and President Biden made June teeth a
Federal holiday none of that saved any
lives none of that reduced crime but
what it did was it made all those white
liberals feel really good inside and and
it kept them from actually saying the
brave stuff which is we've got a serious
crime problem on this show for years we
were saying to the left changing school
names uh team mascots getting rid of
statues that doesn't help fight crime or
look isolation or mental illness how
many lives did they actually cost
chasing statues instead of criminals
telling us that this was the action that
you had to take it didn't alleviate any
crime or any illness or any drug
addiction hardly it Amplified it because
it kept people from actually doing the
work Tyrus has made this point over and
over again it was never about the public
to begin with it were activated
activists elevating themselves and
saying the most strident things possible
to fund the police all whites are racist
there's an infrastructure that is
inherently waste racist that way they
would get funding they would get houses
they would get book deals and no one
would speak against this out of fear
because nobody wants to be called a
racist so in turn they accelerated and
Amplified division while ending up
making a buck I think the worst thing
that they did was that they erased the
idea the Primacy of the individual right
they now every person is no longer
different from every person they're just
part of a group and what they did well
the reason why they did that was then
you could then pit group versus group
when in fact you could have a white
person could have more in common with a
black person an Asian person could have
more in common with a Mexican person but
you can't have that instead you have to
put them in groups and put them against
each other what you end up with riots
looting crime because you can't speak
out because if you did you'd be racist
so now we're living in the world of
elite capture when in fact it was this
pure unmitigated cowardice wow hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else